all right so I had Ground zeroes
reserved at Gamestop but I thought aha
Walmart's open at midnight I can buy it
there right no apparently it said it's
been recalled when they tried to ring me
up went to two different Walmart's so
apparently you can't buy ground zeroes
if you're me going there at midnight but
I thought aha
all the things for a reason maybe the
divine power God Himself is like Jeremy
you need to review a telltale games
Walking Dead Season 2 episode 2 so I was
like all right let's do that let's
review it
[Music]
Telltale Games The Walking Dead Season 2
episode 2 a house divided holy [ __ ]
those titles just get longer so when a
house divided he plays Clementine she's
still with the same crew she was with
before but this episode is like for me
it was the Empire Strikes Back a Walking
Dead seriously the whole theme of this
is antitrust who do you trust who do you
side with this dude comes in and this
was the most menacing thing ever this
guy walks into the house he's just
walking around asking you questions you
realize you feel like a little girl but
you're supposed to feel like in The
Walking Dead you play as Clementine but
this part did it clearly it was like
this guy could just hold you down just
beat your head and if you want done he
was answers out of you for me I never
picked the little dot dot dot answer
with this one I was just dot dot dot
don't give him anything don't give him
[ __ ] guy and his mustache deconstructed
a chess game just by looking at it I'm
not telling him [ __ ] but he was like you
don't even know the group you're with do
you and you realize you don't yeah
you're with them because being in a
group helps the little girl survived a
zombie apocalypse but you realize you
don't really know these folks so right
there anti-trust the seed is planted in
your brain and you go and you meet this
other crew it all right this spoiler
alert I'm gonna put spoiler alert down
here if you haven't played season 2
episode 2 but I have to talk about this
[ __ ] I'll leave it I won't move my lips
when I say the name holy [ __ ] dude
kidneys alone he was alive dude I was
looking at him like hug worse options
yes hug Kenny that's what I did I just
ran up and gave the dude a hug I was
just I felt the knot in your throat the
song's picking up from season one you're
like the luggage so holy [ __ ] that dude
granted he's not the most stable
individual ever but you see still feels
like family but after that conflict and
strife and things are happening people
are questioning you like poor Clementine
seriously everyone puts their [ __ ] on
her shoulder so like hey
and I know I'm like 45 years old but I
need to tell you this keep a secret all
right and then they tell you life and
death [ __ ] you're like why would you put
that on a little girl's shoulders for
her to carry now you have two groups
this is the house divide us I was like
well I mean if it comes down to it I
want to go with these folks I know you
guys have been around for an episode I
really appreciate it but they seemed
more family issue but then [ __ ] goes
down which is really funny because I
mean someone comes in it's like all
right I'm gonna start breaking fingers I
want this person to come out here now
and I was like well I'm writing that guy
off is dead I guess is how I think in
the zombie apocalypse I'm like ah he's
toast all right let me go out the window
try to find this other person so I did
that my friend sitting in the room was
like that's funny I didn't do that after
that it was just like holy [ __ ]
monumental things happen I'm not saying
folks dives a couple might by the end of
this episode you leave it feeling like
Luke Skywalker getting his little
prosthetic and you're like well that
surely sucked ass I feel like episode 3
we're going to be in a very dark place
our story short this was one of my
favorite episodes of The Walking Dead
Season 1 or 2 anything you can tell the
game makers at telltale games they were
like all right we need to really hit
hard here we need people to question
loyalty we need people to question their
decisions and we need people to live
with the decisions they make we're going
hardcore this time around they did it
really well seriously man I just want a
Firefly game from Telltale Games do you
guys watch my videos telltale please
tell me that could happen somehow
sometimes I see The Walking Dead Season
2 episode 2 a house divided have you
played it what did you think about it
holy [ __ ] whatever you thought comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]